this summer saw the release of Pokemon
go and Pokemon Sun and Moon drops this
fall but those aren't the only pokemon
games were getting this year I'm Tony
and this game spot news update comes
straight from the tandoor region Pokemon
uranium is a completely new totally fan
made game nine years in the making and
it's available now it's set in the
tandoor region featuring 150 totally
original Pokemon and a new nuclear type
the game seeks to recapture the magic of
the classic versions and you can
download it from the pokemon uranium
website it runs on pc with no emulator
required and a mac version is in the
works if you're interested in pokemon
uranium you should probably get on that
pretty quickly if history has taught us
anything the inevitable cease and desist
letter from Nintendo is already in the
mail in fact a takedown notice just hit
one of the biggest Metroid to remakes
but for now the tandoor region is
waiting for you and if you want to keep
up with all the latest pokemon news
you're already in the right place